Being a mandalorians isn’t just
learning about how to fight
the creed is how we survived
without the creed.
What are we?
This is the way.
Hang on, kid.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie. This is the way.
This will be my Mandalorian
Season 3 Episode 2 Trailer Video.
There's even more stuff they're setting up
even more Easter eggs from the Lord.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
We're also doing a giveaway for Disney
plus memberships.
All you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber
and post all your predictions for episode
two on the video.
Careful for spoilers from episode one
if you haven't seen it yet.
But at the end of episode one,
The Mandalorian and Grogu,
who came to Calabar to one of the planets
in the Mandalorian system
near their homeworld Mandalore.
It's the ancestral home planet of House
Cree, so Bo-Katan didn't build
that castle there.
It's built
in the classical mandalorian style, but
it would have been built by her ancestors
hundreds, if not thousands of years ago.
That's why the mural behind her
throne here
depicts The Mandalorian Civil Wars,
because that was many thousands
of years ago.
In present day, she's just
the current leader of their house.
Because remember her sister, Duchess.
The teen died during the Clone Wars.
All those theories about Obi-Wan
secretly having a love child with her.
It's always funny to see people ask Dave
Filoni about that.
We're going back to Sundari, the main city
where she was killed in the throne room
by Darth Maul.
So we might get some Easter eggs
reduction as a team.
But the reason why you see the Night
Owl banners all over the place
in the throne room, probably over
the rest of the castle,
is because she's the leader of their house
and she's the leader of the Night Owls.
The night owls used to be just a female
fighting force of Mandalorians.
Then she joined the death
Watch Mandalorians during Clone Wars
for a little while. When that happened,
the night Owls joined them too.
Then she eventually left.
In the night I was left with her.
The reason why she's important for episode
two is that she had the information
Mando needed in order to find the living
waters beneath Mandalore
and fulfill his quest to reclaim his honor
per the creed of the death.
Watch Mandalorians.
His group of Mandalorians.
The Armor's group Bo-Katan,
keeps calling him a child of the watch
the children of the watch.
But that's just short for death.
Watch the connection to Jon
Favreau's character,
who's obviously one of the showrunners
of The Mandalorian with Dave Filoni.
But while he was shooting
the first Iron Man movie,
they were doing the sound at Skywalker
Sound at the Skywalker Ranch.
Dave Filoni needed someone for an episode,
so he volunteered himself.
He played previously in George Lucas,
created the Darksaber for that episode.
This lightsaber was stolen
from your Jedi temple
by my ancestors
during the fall of the Old Republic.
Since then, many Jedi have died
upon its blade, even though canonically
they said it was created by Tar Vizsla,
his ancestor, a thousand years ago.
Him wielding it in
the episode was the first time
it had appeared anywhere in Star Wars.
In present day now, Jon Favreau is voicing
the heavy infantryman
whose name is Paz
Vizsla. He's his descendant.
One of the reasons why he felt like
he had a claim to the Darksaber.
It was forged by my ancestor,
founder of House Up,
and now I will win it from you.
You see a bunch of footage of Mando
going beneath the caves in Sun Ra here
and looking at some of the ruins.
This is just the ruins of that main city
that we kept seeing during Clone Wars
and Star Wars Rebels.
It was the main city that her sister,
Duchess, the teen Kryze ruled from,
and it was the city that Darth
Maul took over when he killed previously
and won the darksaber from him.
Then killing Duchess the teen.
There's so much history with Darth Maul,
The Mandalorian ends in the darksaber,
so we'll see if they reference
that when they go back to Mandalore.
But in present day, Darth Maul is dead.
He was killed by Obi-Wan
during Star Wars rebels
before the events of the original trilogy
killed for the second time
because Obi-Wan thought
that he killed him at the end of Phantom
Menace.
There were a couple of jokes
about that too.
Be sure you kill him
this time. He's hard to kill.
But the city where they're going
is where the main throne room is.
So I'm hoping we get to see
the throne room in live action.
Just because a lot of Bo-Katan
conversation with Mando was about him
using the Darksaber to lead their people
as per their tradition.
And he clearly has a legitimate claim
to the throne of Mandalore
because he has the darksaber.
There's still so much to unpack with
what happened with the Darksaber
after the events of Star Wars rebels
because it was given to Bo-Katan.
But per the armor, like one of the reasons
why she doesn't like Bo-Katan
is because she didn't win it in combat.
Sabine Wren gave it to her.
Maybe they'll reference that once
they've been cameos on the series
or if she cameos during The Mandalorian.
Like did Moff Gideon beat her in combat?
I think that's less likely
because Bo-Katan is pretty tough.
He may have taken it from her by force.
The area where you see him going
beneath the civic center here,
beneath the caves with Roku
and Bo-Katan is the area where Ahsoka
faced Darth Maul in the tunnels
at the end of the Clone Wars.
You also see Bo-Katan talking directly
to Grogu, which we haven't seen before.
We'll think of her as space mom
in this equation.
Like if you're going to pick the armor
or bo-katan inside here,
like who do you want to see with
Mandalorian? Who's space?
Mom with space, Dad?
Maybe when we get to season
four, Grogu will parent trap
the two of them using the force?
The only reason why he didn't direct
one of the episodes like
he did during Mandalorian season two,
like he directed Ahsoka's
episode was because when they were filming
Mandalorian Season three,
he was also busy writing and directing
all the episodes of the Ahsoka series,
which is going to premiere later
this year.
The big rumor right now is
we won't see the full Ahsoka trailer
until Star Wars celebration,
but I do think they'll have some moments
this season that will help
set up the Ahsoka series.
And if you haven't watched
those Clone Wars
episodes, the last couple where she fights
Darth Maul in the Mandalorians
main throne room,
it is probably one of the best lightsaber
fights
you will see in live action or animation.
This style of sword
fighting that we wanted to suck in, dude,
Very quick, very acrobatic.
It's hopefully one of the best fights
we did, if not the best lightsaber fight.
This footage of Mando finding
the old Mandalorian helmets in the rubble,
and because Bo-Katan is looking
for redemption, it feels like she's on
this Han Solo type of arc
where she starts out as a nonbeliever.
Like Han Solo didn't believe in the force.
But Luke Skywalker, Mando and Grogu,
who totally believe in it
and they'll probably wind up
finding something or something will happen
while he's busy in the caves there
that will make her more of a believer
or set her on the path
so that by the end of the season
she'll come around a little bit more.
There are a couple really big flashbacks
to Mandalore
before it was destroyed in the Purge,
And the fact that there's grass
in the fields here
makes me feel like this is taking place
way before the Clone Wars.
Because if you don't know the history
of the Mandalorian people,
they basically scorched their own planet
and made it uninhabitable.
During the Mandalorian Civil wars in those
took place thousands of years ago.
That's why they moved Under Dome cities,
because they rendered
their planet uninhabitable.
So when the Empire bonded to slag
during the Great Purge,
it was just pouring salt on the wound.
Their planet had already been destroyed.
A couple of times.
I'm not sure if some of this footage
is from episode two, our Future episodes.
But you see Mando
go on a mission with the heavy infantrymen
and other people
from the armors group on that planet.
The Imperial Thai interceptors
chasing the Mandalorian ship might be
Bo-Katan ship closer to present day
or might be part of the flashbacks
to Mandalore before the Great Purge.
But the ship they're chasing
is just like Bo-Katan ship.
It's a Mandalorian Starfighter.
Some of you've also started
asking more questions about Grogu
and talking like, When will Brochu talk?
Because he's over 50 years old now.
Like it's been a couple of years
since season one.
So he's even older at this point.
He did make some sounds
when the Armorer was talking to Mando
at the beginning of the episode.
You did so of your own free will.
You are no longer
mandalorian, even though
it just sounds like a baby making noise.
I think that's his way of communicating.
Like he was actually speaking in Mando
Inserted to understand him,
so he's kind of speaking, but not in the
traditional way like you would expect.
Like when Yoda speaks.
Even though it's backward speech.
He's speaking in basic, the common
language of the galaxy that you have.
I would say.
Have you liked him?
Yes. Oh.
Oh, great warrior.
Right.
So it is totally possible that Grogu
you can already speak and just chooses
not to speak in basic like you just
speaking in his own native language,
the scene of him using the force
on that beast in the crystalline caves
is Mandalorian like it's meant to look
just like the fragment
that Mando showed in the armor.
And he'll probably decode
the symbols on that,
and it will probably lead him
to something special in the caves.
Remember, Bo-Katan
told him that the rivers that he's looking
for is where their forges used to be.
Beneath the city, where they used to smelt
all their best car into armor,
weapons, everything that they used it in.
So basically, Mando is traveling
to like the main forge of the planet
Mandalore really hoping
they find some cool artifacts,
like maybe something from Mandalore
the Great
or just something really important
that he can bring back and show the armor
to prove that he went there.
Let me know in the comments.
What do you think that Mando and Grogu
you in Bo-Katan will find in those caves
that will help bring her around
and help him redeem himself?
Like make the armor believe in him more
because he does that to prove to her
that he actually did fulfill that quest.
He can't just show up and say,
Oh, you know, I bathed in the water.
It's fine.
He has to, like, show her something
to prove that he did it.
Episode two is supposed to be way
crazier than episode one.
I'm sure there's going to be a billion
Easter eggs.
So if you have any questions
or anything that you spotted
in the trailer
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write it below in the comments.
Everyone click here for My Full
Mandalorian Season 3 episode 1 video
and click here for my Ahsoka
trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe.
And this is the way.